so December has been a pretty big month
for Disney trailers and whilst there
have been rumors of an episode 9 1 we
still haven't got it yet
however the Internet is rife with rumors
and leaks about the trailer and
throughout this video I'll be piecing
together everything we know so far in
order to build the best picture of the
movie before the trailer drops without
the way I'm definition and welcome to
the channel where I ruin it so you don't
have to so from the last year I and
leaked information on the trailer it's
pretty clear that the movie will focus
on the final battle between the first
order led by supreme leader kylo Ren and
the resistance the resistance is still
led by princess leia and apparently
Disney have managed to incorporate the
character into the movie even though
Carrie Fisher is no longer with us
the trailer is reportedly heavily
narrated by kylo Ren and we get a return
of his acolyte the Knights of Ren who
appeared briefly in the force awakens it
was unclear exactly what happened to
them and why they were absent but one
could guess that they have been away
building their skills and with they're
now being ruined for a Sith apprentice
they may even battle it out for a
position at kylo side JJ Abrams clearly
wanted some focus on this group so it
seems like a course correction after
they were missing from the prior film
Finn and Poe are apparently seen atop
some horse like creatures as they ride
on a new planet that seems very
vegetative on this planet they meet two
new resistance characters played by
dominic monaghan
and at naomi Aki Aki is rumored to be
playing Landau's daughter and this is
pretty much confirmed by the
reappearance of the character in the
trailer who was shown to be back on
board the Millennium Falcon Ray has
reforged her lightsaber and seems like
the complete Jedi now much in the same
way that Luke was by The Return of the
Jedi as of now this is all of the
information that I can find from various
newspapers and other videos but exactly
what happens will be revealed in due
time with a full trailers release so
what are your thoughts on the leaked
information on the new trailer comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and check
out my breakdown of this week's other
big trailer Hellboy which will be linked
at the
and this is a channel for people who are
super into Star Wars so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]